Okay, now that you have a basic
understanding of Q learning,
let's consider how we can turn
the stock trading problem
into a problem that Q
learning can solve.
To do that we need to
define our actions,
we need to define our state, and
we also need to define our rewards.
Let's start here first with actions.
It's actually pretty easy.
We just have three actions,
buy, sell or do nothing.
So let's consider how that might
play out with an actual stock, and
let's suppose we've already
trained our Q learner what to do.
Let's see what's likely to happen.
So usually what's going to happen most
frequently is that we do nothing.
There will occasionally be buys and
sells, but usually nothing.
Well, at least, that's my expectation,
we'll have to see when we create
these learners what actually happens.
So we are evaluating
the factors of the stock.
In other words, we compute, say,
several technical indicators.
That is our state.
We consider that state and
we do nothing.
So let's suppose we do nothing for
quite a long period here,
but somehow or another,
after a little while, boom, something
triggers and says we should buy.
So we buy the stock
here we're holding it.
We do nothing, nothing, nothing,
nothing, nothing, nothing, and
boom, our very intelligent Q learner
says, hey now is the time to sell.
And we continue like that through
the rest of our time series.
Let's consider now what these buys and
sells, how they affect
our portfolio value.
So we start out with whatever
we've got in the bank and
there's no trading for a while.
Suddenly there's a buy, and
then we see an increase in our
portfolio value until we hit that sell.
Then nothing.
Again, another buy, and a sell.
So you see this sort
of stepped behavior.
Now of course, because I was drawing
this and I wanted us to look good,
I was choosing opportunistic
times to buy and sell.
Your real strategy is
probably not going to be so
good, but ideally this is the kind
of thing we'd like to see.